Follow Lane,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the Celtic languages.
Celtic languages are today spoken mainly
in the British isles where they've
existed alongside English since the
Middle Ages.
The numbers are not exactly clear
because the Celtic languages have gone
through declines and revivals and people
have varying degrees of ability,
so we'll take these numbers with a grain
of salt,
but there are around a million speakers
of Celtic languages in total.
That includes Welsh with around 508,000
speakers and around 310,000
fluent speakers mainly in Wales.
Then there's Irish Gaelic which has
around 80,000
proficient speakers who use it outside
of school,
but around 2 million people have at
least some knowledge of it mainly in
Ireland and to some extent in Northern
Ireland.
Then they're Scottish Gaelic which has
around 57,000
native speakers and around 87,000
people with some knowledge of the
language mainly in Scotland.
There is also a small Scottish Gaelic
community of around 2,300
people in Cape Breton Nova Scotia in
Canada.
Then there's the Breton language spoken
by around 226,000
people,
mainly in the Brittany region of France,
that figure of 226,000
include students in bilingual schools.
Then there's the cornish language spoken
in Cornwall,
which came close to extinction in the
19th century,
but has undergone a revival and now has
a few thousand fluent speakers and then
there's the manx language spoken on the
Isle of Man,
which has only around a hundred native
speakers and a couple thousand people
who can speak some makes today.
They're not spoken by a very large
number of people and they're mostly
limited to the British isles and to
Brittany in France,
but historically the Celtic languages
were spoken over a much larger area than
they are today.
During the first millennium bce.
They were spoken across much of Europe
from the Iberian Peninsula all the way
over to the Black Sea and even in parts
of Asia Minor.
One probable Prodo Celtic culture was
the earned field culture of central
Europe in the late Bronze Age.
It was a flourishing culture from around
1200 bce.
It's language was at least likely an
early form of Celtic,
if not protocol t,
and we think so partly based on place
name evidence,
protal Celtic developed into various
Celtic languages which were spoken over
a wide area in Europe.
The earliest attested tested Celtic
languages.
The pontic language,
the language of the goal of culture that
descended from the earned field culture.
There are about 140 the pontic
inscriptions that were discovered in
northern Italy and southern Switzerland.
These inscriptions date from around 550
bce to 100 bce.
The gullah culture had strong
connections with the neighboring house.
That culture,
the major celtic culture at that time,
these languages on the European mainland
and in Asia Minor,
I'll refer to as the continental
languages.
This is a geographic grouping,
not a linguistic one,
and there are no particular linguistic
innovations that would make them a
linguistic.
Here are some continental Celtic
languages that might ring a bell.
There's the goldfish language spoken in
dl within Presente de France and
Galician spoken in Asia minor around
present day,
Ankara,
Turkey.
The continental Celtic languages are all
extinct.
Celtic speakers began to die out or
become assimilated into the Roman
culture by around 200 bce before the
death and assimilation of Celtic
speakers on the mainland,
some Celtic speakers migrated to the
British isles.
The Celtic languages that developed in
the British isles are known as the
insular Celtic languages.
The insular Celtic languages are still
alive today.
There are two groups of insular Celtic
languages,
Cute Celtic or Goy Delek languages which
include Irish,
Scottish,
and makes Gaelic and the PA Celtic or
nick languages which include Breton,
cornish,
and Welsh.
These two groups of insular Celtic
languages are not intelligible with each
other,
but within each group there is some
degree of intelligibility depending on
the dialect being spoken.
The two groups of insular Celtic
languages evolved from a common
ancestor.
The oldest known insular Celtic language
is a form of Archaic Irish,
sometimes called Primitive Irish.
It is found in the argument scriptions
from the early fourth century CE
organism,
an alphabet that was used to write Irish
as a group from primitive Irish into old
Irish and was used until about the ninth
century.
Old Irish eventually developed into the
modern Irish Gaelic up today.
Speakers of old Irish also migrated to
Scotland where it eventually developed
into Scottish Gaelic and to the Isle of
man where it evolved into banks.
While primitive Irish,
a rosen,
Ireland common [inaudible] Rosen,
Great Britain.
Common Bottleneck is the ancestor of all
the PA,
Celtic or [inaudible] languages.
The pick dish language which went
extinct by the twelfth century Ce may
have been a sonic language,
but it's possible that pick dish was
related to sonic but not descended from
it.
Over the course of a few centuries,
protonic dialects evolved into Welsh,
cornish,
Breton,
and come brick,
which is extinct.
The Celtic languages were under great
pressure during this time.
Breton is in fact spoken in continental
Europe in the Brittany region of France,
even though it's an insular Celtic
language.
It has been spoken there since the sixth
century CE,
when some Celtic speakers fled during
the Anglo Saxon invasion of Britain.
Coexistence with English Britain was
ruled by the Romans from 43 Ce to 410
seat,
but after the departure of the Romans,
the Anglo saxons began to invade
Britain.
In Britain,
the Anglo saxons conquered the Celtic
peoples and either eliminated them or
intermarried with them,
depending on the source,
you consult eventually replacing the
Celtic languages with old English,
but not in Wales and Cornwall,
which remained Celtic in Scotland.
Gaelic speakers from Ireland migrated to
the west coast around the same time that
Anglo saxons migrated to the east coast.
Then Scottish Gaelic began to develop in
Scotland,
Gaelic coexisted with the old English
dialects that would later develop into
Scotts and Scotts English,
and in the year 17 or seven,
Scotland formed a union with England and
Wales,
the Kingdom of Great Britain.
After that,
Scottish Gaelic began to diminish and
use partly because English was the
language of universal education.
Scottish Gaelic is today considered
definitely endangered by UNESCO as World
Language Project Wales came under the
control of England in the year 12,
82.
Welsh has continued to be spoken until
the present day,
but for a long time.
English was given preference as the
official language and in the 19th and
20th centuries,
Welsh declined rapidly in favor of
English,
but efforts have been made to conserve
the Welsh language and everybody learns
at least some of it in school and some
people take their entire public school
education in Welsh,
and as I mentioned before,
it currently has hundreds of thousands
of native speakers.
Cornwall was under English control by
the mid 19th century.
Their language began to disappear after
England passed the act of uniformity and
15,
58.
This was a law that made English the
sole language of church services.
The cornish language almost became
extinct and it was actually a
temporarily declared extinct by UNESCO,
but a revival movement in the 20th
century has given new life to the
language and it is now taught in some
schools and there are now about 300
fluent cornish speakers on the isle of
Man.
The manx language is in a similar
situation.
It almost became extinct,
but a revival movement has resulted in a
few hundred fluent speakers of the
language.
There is also a manx language primary
school.
They're creating a new generation of
make speakers.
Ireland became an English colony from
1169 to 1949.
Irish remained the majority language
there until the 19th century when it was
overtaken by English.
Despite strong intentions to support and
revive the Irish language,
it continues to decline in favor of
English.
It is taught in schools,
but not many people use the language of
their own volition outside of schools
and similar to Scottish Gaelic,
it is considered definitely endangered.
The Brittany region became part of
France in the 16th century.
In France.
There is no official recognition of any
regional languages.
The majority of Breton speakers today
are in their sixties or older and the
number of speakers could be dropping by
$10,000
per year.
It is considered severely endangered by
UNESCO.
Now let's look at some features of
Celtic languages in general.
Celtic languages feature vsl,
word order.
Actually Continental Celtic languages
probably had freer word order,
but let's focus on the Living Celtic
languages.
Here's an example of vsl word order.
In Irish Gaelic.
This sentence means I saw the man this
morning,
Honickman farrier margin word for word.
It's see past tense.
I the man on morning.
You can see that it's vs.
Oh,
another sentence.
This one means the man was painting a
chair yesterday.
He and Ferric Pancho cohere in a word
for word.
It's be in past tense.
The man,
progressive paint chair yesterday.
You can see that it's vsl with the
auxiliary verb coming in first position
and the main lexical verb coming after
the subject,
and then there's the object next Celtic
languages feature inflected
prepositions,
which are basically a combination of a
preposition and a personal pronoun.
Let's look at an example from Welsh.
The preposition meaning on his ad and
the stem that comes before inflections
is at,
so we have on me out of notch on us,
on you,
singular on you,
plural,
on him,
on her,
out of in on them,
out of a similar kind of inflected
preposition exists in Semitic languages
like Hebrew and Arabic.
Next Celtic languages feature initial
consonant mutations.
That is a change in the consonant at the
beginning of a word,
depending on its context.
For example,
if the word is preceded by a definite
article in the genitive case,
let's take a look at this in Irish,
so we have the word for men fair,
but if we want to say of the men,
it becomes unfair and it's similar for
the date of case.
If we want to say to the men,
it becomes to unfair,
the unfair.
It may be hard to hear a difference in
that continent,
but there is a sort of softening of the
f sound in some dialects.
That mutated consonant sounds something
like a v sound in other dialects.
It's silent not only continent
mutations,
but also vowel mutations occur in Celtic
languages as a morphological device.
Let's look at some examples from Welsh
that will mutations can be used in
forming different parts of speech,
becomes a sold the noun hio meaning son
becomes the adjective.
Hey,
look,
meaning Sunny Vale mutations can also be
used in the formation of a plural who
becomes a so the singular noun,
cool meaning boat becomes God,
meaning boats,
Celtic languages,
also feature and impersonal verb form,
serving as a passive or in transitive.
An example from Welsh discussion means I
teach the scared means is taught or one
teaches.
This is an impersonal verb that is not
conjugated for person.
An example from Irish Munoz,
I teach moon.
Cer is taught,
one teaches in English.
There was no specific verb form
dedicated to the passive.
You need to use an auxiliary verb plus
the past participle,
which has some other functions as well.
Differences between the PA Celtic
languages and the q Celtic languages.
These two groups of languages have had
thousands of years to divert,
so there are a lot more differences
between the two branches than there are
between the languages within them.
There are a lot of cognate words shared
between the two groups of languages,
but you could say that they are distant
cognates because sound changes and
spelling changes have made the words
unrecognizable.
In many cases,
the labels,
PA,
Celtic and q Celtic reflect the way
these two groups developed from Provo
Celtic.
If we look at the cognates that are
shared between both branches in the PA
Celtic branch,
there are words that commonly begin with
P or b.
well,
in the queue Celtic branch,
they begin with C or k or q.
for example.
The word for what in Irish,
it's Cain and in Welsh it's bad.
There are some other common sound
differences too.
For example,
words beginning with s followed by e or
I,
which make a shift sound.
In the Delek languages often begin with
h in the languages,
so the word for old in Irish is Shan
ended Welsh.
It's and despite their coexistence with
English over the centuries,
the Celtic languages are very distinct
from English and they're an important
part of the history and the culture and
identity of the United Kingdom and
Ireland as well as Brittany in France,
but today most of the Celtic languages
are considered to be endangered with the
English language and French dominating
whether the Celtic languages survive or
not,
depends on the communities to which they
are native and that brings me to the
question of the day for people from a
community where a Celtic language has
traditionally been spoken to you speak a
Celtic language.
Do you speak that language outside of
school?
How valuable do you think it is to be
able to speak that language?
Let us know in the comments down below.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and once again I'd like to say thank you
to my patrion supporters,
especially these ones right here for
their monthly pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.